-Welcome back, Bryan.
We love having you here, bud.
-Thank you.
Good to be here.
-You're a very busy, busy man.
I follow you on the socials
and in all the media
and everything.
I read what you're up to.
You're traveling the world
or the country
-Yeah.
-with this Dos Hombres mezcal.
-Yes.
-That you're doing
with Aaron Paul.
-Dos Hombres.
[ Cheering ]
-Yes, yes.
-I mean, you're going all
over the place.
You surprise people
and you surprise liquor stores
and you just show up
and they're like...
-We do.
-..."What's going on?"
[ Laughter ]
-I know. It's pretty wild.
It's as close to, you know,
a rock tour
as my fantasy will allow me
to go, you know...
[ Laughter ]
...because we go to these places
and we sign bottles for fans
and things and they love it.
-I have a video of this
because I wanted to show this.
This is a video of one of the
events that you guys showed up.
Look at the reaction on this.
-Here we go. Here we go.
Here we go. Here we go.
Let's go.
-Alright, let's go!
-[ Screaming ]
-Ohhh!
-Dude, look at all these people.
-Wow!
-Look at this.
-[ Screaming ]
-Dude, that's crazy!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's so fun!
-It's so much fun.
And doing it with Aaron,
you know, my partner
on "Breaking Bad,"
he's such a great guy
and to do Dos Hombres
with him is a thrill.
-I was looking at something else
as I was searching online
for things about you and I saw
that a pair of Walter White's
underwear went up for auction...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I heard about this.
-...for $32,000.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I should mention,
these were never worn.
-Those were never worn.
The ones that are soiled go
for much higher.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
Is that --
-I wish I didn't say that.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
But could you imagine?
30,000.
-I mean, people are crazy!
-Yeah!
-Who, in their right mind,
is buying a pair
of tighty-whitey underwears
for 30 grand?
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
-Sorry.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I didn't -- I didn't --
It didn't go through on my Venmo
yet, but it's close, yeah.
It's Venmo.
-Alright, give it time.
-You've also been
making headlines recently
because someone asked you
who would you like
to play in a biopic
and you've probably been asked
this a bunch of times
and you were like,
"I don't know, Willie Nelson?"
-Yeah, I thought Willie Nelson
because I think I resemble him.
I'm old and craggy and...
[ Laughter ]
...you know?
So, yeah,
I think I could do
Willie Nelson.
What do you think?
Can I do a Willie?
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-But also, the other names --
the other name that came up
is Gordon Lightfoot.
-Oh, do you remember him?
-Canadian legend.
-Yes.
-Legend!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Here's Gordon Lightfoot.
[ Whistles ]
-Yeah!
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah. Can you do? Yeah.
Can we do?
Yeah, I could see that.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Sundown ♪
♪ You better take care ♪
♪ If I find
you've been creepin' ♪
♪ round my back stairs ♪
-"Sundown" was a good one.
♪ Sundown ♪
And then --
♪ If you could ♪
-♪ Read my mind, love ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ What a tale
my thoughts would tell ♪
-I'm watching
this movie tomorrow.
[ Laughter ]
I would watch this tomorrow.
♪ Just like an old-time movie ♪
-How about --
I'm going into like Bowie.
-[ As Bowie ]
♪ An old-time movie ♪
-Another one that came up
that someone said
that you should play
is Stan Lee.
-Oh, from -- yeah, from the --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah. Yes.
[ Whistling ]
-I actually have --
-Oh.
Stan Lee glasses?
-I have sunglasses,
if you could maybe try --
-Ooh.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Now, this -- I look like
I'm right out of the '70s.
-Yay!
-I'm a porn star, you know.
[ Laughter ]
How you doing?
-I like --
-I should be chewing gum.
-I like that look.
[ New York accent ]
Bryan Cranston is here!
-How you doing?
-Hey, how you doing?
-How's youse doing?
-Is this guy giving you
a problem?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa! Whoa!
-Is this guy --
this guy here giving you
a problem?
-No problem here.
-I'm just saying.
-We don't want any problem here.
-Don't make me do this.
[ Laughter ]
-How about this?
-I have my tissues.
-No, he's got tissues.
No more sneezing.
Allergy season.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I did have,
though, just in case?
-What have you got?
You have all kinds of props.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm like I've turned into like
a prop comic here.
I just wanted to see what you
look like as Willie Nelson.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Would you do it?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Let's do it, okay.
♪♪
Oh, that's pretty good.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[Indistinct]
[ Whistling ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ To all the girls I've loved ♪
♪ Before ♪
-Oh, I love -- great!
♪ Who traveled in and out ♪
-Wait, this is --
[ Laughter ]
-♪ My door ♪
-We'll get a real beard.
When you do the movie.
[ Laughter ]
Yes! Do it like that.
So Willie!
That's so Willie!
-♪ I'm glad they came along ♪
-Willie always did that!
-♪ I dedicate this song ♪
-Willie always did that.
[ Laughter ]
Make that his thing.
That's the thing you do
when you do his biopic,
you make Willie always do this.
-Just always is?
-He always holds his beard up.
-Always holds --
-Yeah.
You're the one who's going
to rewrite history
and tell the story.
-I know. It's fabulous.
-I could see you
as Willie Nelson.
-Could you?
I actual-- I'm not kidding.
I really could see that.
[ Laughter ]
No. He doesn't do that.
-He doesn't do that?
-No, he doesn't do that, either.
[ Laughter ]
Can we talk about "Your Honor"?
-Is it a good look?
Should I keep this look?
[ Cheering and applause ]
You know what?
Yeah, I have to ask my wife
on that
because she's very sensitive
about the look of the man
she married 35 years ago.
[ Laughter ]
-But, I mean, look at you
in Season 2, though, of --
-Yeah, that's why.
-of "Your Honor."
This is you. This is --
Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's a look right there, bud.
-I can't -- my wife absolutely
refused to have, uh,
relations with me, shall we say?
[ Laughter ]
-I love how you
censored yourself.
Thank you so much.
Yes, I understand
what you're saying.
-Yes.
-She refused.
[ Laughter ]
-She refused. She said,
"I'm not going to --
No, I'm not going to go
to bed with that."
-Wow!
-That's not a thing.
Will you go to bed --
My wife is in the audience.
Will you go to bed with this?
-Yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
She's somewhere.
Where is she?
-She says yes. She says yes.
-Alright, good.
-But also,
you had a pretty interesting --
a little trivia
about your beard here.
-Oh, well, I was going
to shave it off earlier,
but I found a nest in there.
[ Laughter ]
These birds.
They were such darling
little birds,
I didn't have the heart to.
-Yeah, a bird was nesting
in there. There's a little home
there, yeah.
-They weren't ready to fly off,
so I kept it.
-There's one episode left
of "Your Honor."
How do we set it up
for anyone who hasn't --
What do we have to expect?
-Well, as long as I can,
you know,
relay this very seriously.
[ Laughter ]
It's a very serious show.
-I forgot to ask you to take --
Would you like
to take that wig off?
-I don't know.
I'm getting kind of used to it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I kind of like it.
Talk to me about "Your Honor."
This is the season finale.
-It's --
You know, I didn't think
there was enough anguish
in the world, Jimmy.
I wanted to bring more --
more tension and stress
to people's lives,
[ Laughter ]
so, I made --
No, after the tragedy
at the end of "Season 1."
-It was so good.
-Oh, thank you.
I wanted to give
the audience a little break
and to see some measure of hope.
I also wanted to explore
what it's like, honestly,
to deal with grief and despair.
And then the last thing was,
is there redemption
in our lives now?
Can someone redeem themselves?
Can you seek forgiveness
and can you grant forgiveness?
And I think it's a strength
of human character
to be able to say you're sorry,
to be able to forget
and forgive.
-Forgive.
-I think it's
an important thing.
-Yeah. Absolutely,
I think it is, too.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Is it the hair?
-It's perfect.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Bryan Cranston
in "Your Honor."
Take a look at this.
-Adam fell to the floor.
I ran inside
and I-I yelled for help.
I held my son
in my arms as he died.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Did you see who shot him?
-Yes.
-And was it the defendant,
Eugene Jones?
♪♪
-Yes, it was.
[ Spectators murmuring ]
-Ooh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
The Season 2 finale --
The Season 2 finale
of "Your Honor" comes
to Showtime this weekend!
More with Bryan Cranston
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.